[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este nuevo avance
informativa en france24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz el secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken se reunió
en berlín la capital alemana con la
canciller de ese país angela merkel con
quien trató temas de la agenda bilateral
así como aspectos para el futuro de
libia blinken afirmó que es necesario el
retiro de las tropas extranjeras de ese
país africano y garantizar elecciones
generales el próximo mes de diciembre
tomás sparrow corresponsal de france 24
en berlín nos da más detalles del
encuentro en el siguiente reporte la
conferencia internacional sobre libia
que se realizó en berlín por invitación
del gobierno alemán y el secretario
general de naciones unidas tuvo como
objetivo acordar los siguientes pasos
hacia la estabilización de ese país que
ha vivido una década de caos y de
violencia esos pasos incluyen un mayor
apoyo de la comunidad internacional así
como también un fortalecimiento del cese
del fuego si bien expertos aquí en verín
han cuestionado sus esfuerzos
internacionales asegurando que no han
hecho suficiente para frenar la
violencia en libia al gobierno alemán sí
reconoció los avances que ha habido en
este país en los últimos meses
con el gobierno de unidad de transición
siguiente el gobierno alemán y en
particular el ministro exterior es algo
más también reconocieron que en libia
enfrenta desafíos muy grandes citando en
particular la necesidad de que se ponga
fin a lo que es yo como la interferencia
militar extranjera asegurando que debe
respetarse el embargo armamentístico y
apoyar también el proceso político que
debería llevar a la realización de
elecciones previstas para finales de
este año en españa fueron puestos en
libertad los nueve líderes separatistas
catalanes que el día de ayer fueron
indultados tras una votación del consejo
de ministros los 9 separatistas estaban
acusados de delitos de malversación y
sedición por el proceso independentista
llevado a cabo en 2017 su indulto fue
propuesto por el presidente del gobierno
pedro sánchez quien defendió su
liberación como una vía para recuperar
la concordia con la comunidad autónoma
catalana una liberación que según
sánchez tiene condiciones con la
justicia española una comitiva del
partido esquerra republicana de
catalunya ha recibido a los liberados
que también fueron recibidos por el
presidente de la generalitat de cata
con eso los excarcelados también han
contado con una fuerte con un fuerte
rechazo de los partidos conservadores
que anunciaron que recurrirán a recursos
judiciales para revertir la medida
carme forcadell ex miembro del partido
catalán y una de las excarceladas dio
declaraciones a los medios tan pronto
como quedó en libertad 3
al que volem es la amnistía hoy es un
día de alegría de alegría especialmente
para las consultas de la presión y
perales nuestras familias pero la
alegría no es completa no es porque
nosotros lo que volvemos la fi de la
represión que todas las personas
represaliadas que surtía al carrer como
nosotros libremente sence por rsc a los
exiliados juventud urna el centro
europeo de prevención y control de
enfermedades indicó que la variante
delta de kobe 19 la más contagiosa que
fue detectada por primera vez en india
representa el representará el 90 por
ciento de los contagios en la unión
europea para finales de agosto informes
preliminares indican que la mutación
delta puede infectar a personas que sólo
han recibido una dosis de la vacuna en
medio del temor un estudio de la
universidad de oxford publicado este
miércoles reveló que los fármacos
producidos por las farmacéuticas
astrazéneca y falset variantes harían
ampliamente efectivos contra la variante
delta y también la variante cup
y finalizamos en alemania la ciudad de
munich amaneció cubierta en arcoiris
número 22 sitios emblemáticos entre los
que se encuentran el ayuntamiento fueron
decorados con las banderas el fbi esto
en respuesta a la negación de la uefa de
iluminar el estadio local con los
colores del arco iris durante el partido
de fútbol entre alemania y hungría en la
primera ronda de la eurocopa el
organismo había dicho en un comunicado
que rechazaba esta solicitud por tener
un contexto político refiriéndose a la
protesta por las leyes anti el fbi
aprobadas en hungría la federación
alemana de fútbol ha anunciado que
entregará 10.000 banderas arcoiris a los
aficionados de esta manera despedimos
este avance informativo en france24
creció con nosotros